hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well so if
this is
moral theory and the plain person
moral theory we can articulate in terms
of things like
texts
we can give them a presentation
i can make you handouts right and why
can i make you handouts because we can
schematize these things
and every moral theory includes you know
some things like you know what is the
nature of a human being what is it to
behave
well what does it depend only bless you
what is it to
to be in touch with the good what is it
to be out of touch with it
some do this better than others like we
talked about motivism
emotivism doesn't give you much guidance
at all
but other ones give you more guidance
how do you make sense out of your life
this is where we get to what we call
therapy what what's a narrative
yeah like i mean i noticed something
reading a story
yeah a story is a is a kind of narrative
right um we've brought up some of this
before when we were talking about how we
learn
for instance when we should apologize
when we shouldn't apologize or
how to behave um every one of your lives
is a narrative
you may have not thought that much about
it up until this point but
you could take your life and if you sat
down and i'm not saying
you should be you know so navel gazing
as to what to spend the rest of your
semester just writing about yourself
but you will do a little bit of that in
this class um
you can sit down and do like a history
of my life up to this point
and whenever you're engaged in moral
reflection you're doing something like
that
you're you're trying to make sense out
of did i do things wrong or right in the
past how have i gotten to where i am
am i on the right track is my is my
inertia going in the right way or am i
like
you know going down is my narrative up
to this point
a history of moral success or moral
failure
or a mix of both or did it start out as
one
and become the other these are questions
that you can you can ask yourself
do you you pose them to yourself like
like that though probably
how do we express stuff like that you
say man i've been screwing up
this this is not the right thing for me
to do
how to how did i get here that's one of
the things that we say to ourselves
or sometimes other people say that to us
they say well you're
you've changed uh i thought i knew you
and then we're you know we think to
ourselves have i changed
i'm not sure i like that and if you say
that to yourself
you're taking a look at your own
narrative
and you're looking at what is the good
for you and
is it the right good have you picked the
right
the right thing to you know the right
star
to align yourself with
um now these narratives
and texts or no
mcintyre says
they allow us to to um sort of make
sense of each other
um two of the texts that we're going to
read later on in the semester
are texts that he mentions in this
section he talks about
aristotle's nick mccain ethics but one
which has to do with the question of
what is happiness and what are
you know right and wrong views about
happiness it's
really a question about what goods would
make us happy then thomas aquinas
asked the same questions in sonateologia
prima secundai
questions two through five stuff i'm
having to read later in the semester
eris again not arizona mcintyre says
those are kind of hard to relate to
and again in in real life and ordinary
moral reasoning
you're not so much looking at texts
you're trying to see how they connect
up with with the story that you're still
living out
and what provides you the interplay
between these
well other kinds of
narratives so
mcintyre would be somebody who would be
very receptive
to saying well you can't do ethics just
by reading aristotle
or just by reading or reading textbooks
you have to do ethics in part by
watching louis ck
and disney and
what else should we pick um
okay barney and uh
mickey's clubhouse okay yeah and these
are all
these are all narratives um by which
people learn you know really basic
things about about good and bad right
and wrong
and you know we can sort of joke about
it but you know the narratives that we
pick
are very important if you had to
criticize things like mickey's clubhouse
or barney
what sort of criticisms would you have
not high enough production value
probably not the criticism right
what criticism might you have
every problem gets solved there's
there's a lack of
of maybe serious consideration of
how difficult ethics and moral issues
can be sometimes
every every issue gets solved within 30
minutes or actually 22 minutes if you
count uh
commercials um and everybody's happy all
the time you know
maybe they're saying a little bit but
then usually everybody's happy by the
end
so maybe there's a little bit of a
pollyannish unrealistic
aspect to that but you know would you
turn out better if the only narrative
that you had was
um mickey mouse's clubhouse then say
if the only narrative that you had was
the song movies that was all that you
had to
align yourself with morally
yeah you probably would just imagine
what somebody would be like if all they
knew was the saw movies that was their
moral compass for the world
you know maybe don't spend too much time
imagining it though right
so this brings me to another point that
mcintyre makes
he talks about the need for certain
kinds of narratives
so the plain person needs needs theory
but the plain person also needs
narratives that can can tie in with them
he says when from time to time the plain
person retrospectively examines what his
or her life amounts to as a whole
often enough with a view to choice
between alternative futures
characteristically what they're what
they're asking is to what conception am
i
good have i committed to myself and now
do i have reason to put it into question
are there narratives that where that
sort of thing happens
are there stories in which that sort of
thing is going on and
actually you know cartoons are one thing
where that's happening when somebody
says
yes i'm going to not lie to my friend
even though it's going to make them
upset they're choosing between two goods
right um
well he says when we as readers or
spectators put
questions to a narrative we look forward
what the universal
in the particular plot and character
have significance for us
as far as we can understand them in
terms of universal conceptions of the
good
when you're talking about somebody's
character you're talking about what they
think is good what their motivation is
and not just what they think is good how
they line up the goods in relation to
each other
um again think of that louis ck episode
different kinds of characters there
don't don't we have them right
nobody's like perfectly good in that one
either are they
but you can you can say some people are
better than others can't you
and he says uh when we look at our own
past lives and we look at the narrative
structure of that
we ask about the universal how it can be
particularized how certain conceptions
of the good
and the virtues take on an embodied form
certain
character traits virtues right and he
says in doing so we character
characteristically draw on resources
provided by some stock of stories
which we earlier learned so
what are the stories that we have at our
disposal
to make sense on immoral matters if all
we have is disney
we're probably going to be taken
advantage of because we're going to
think that people are better than they
are
right same thing with barney too right i
mean barney's
or teletubbies or any of these these
kids shows because they're made
non-threatening
and they're trying to get kids to
actually like not behave like the little
monsters that they can easily become
and so they have a very important
civilizing effect that i don't want to
denigrate but what are other important
stories that we have from making sense
out of these things
think about how you've figured out your
own life up to this point
what stories have you relied on yeah
experiences from my parents yeah well
you know when i asked you guys
um what are the what are the resources
that you use for moral decision making
i would say at least half of the the
responses that i got were
parents and i'm willing to bet that most
of you have parents who are
fairly good models
tends to go with you know the athletes
of mayor students
that's good i'm not knocking that by the
way i'm pointing that out
i'm saying that's a good thing so you
can look at your parents stories
you can also look at where your parents
screwed up
and it's very easy too by the way to say
i'm never gonna be like that
you know and then you find yourself
later on unless you
pay very close attention doing the same
things that they do
could we expand this to other people's
narratives like
your other family members older brothers
and sisters
uncles aunts friends
friends fit in there colleagues
classmates do you guys use each other's
stories to figure things out bless you
not necessarily just you know should i
trust that person i don't like their
story
you know but like you know are your
stories relevant to each other
who who else or what other kinds of
stories or characters do you use to make
sense out of
your life yeah it's like religion in the
bible
if you were raised up yeah um
there's more to say the bible than just
a bunch of narratives
if you really want to find some some
books that are very dry reading
read some of the
jewish law and you know this
this mid spot that mid spot and you're
like oh my god what is this going to get
get done so there's a story again
right but yeah you're right people
people use
those stories to make sense of things as
a matter of fact
a lot of religious leaders chose the
story form
precisely to convey messages you know
sometimes
if you look at the bible
every once in a while they'd go up to
this this jesus guy and say
hey what should we do about this and
they say let me tell you a story
and that aft at the end they'd be like
okay what's the point of that he'd be
like yeah exactly
and the same thing you can find with the
relation between the quran and the
hadith
there's a lot of narratives there what
else though
i mean for that works for those who are
involved in that sort of lifestyle
you guys are constantly interacting with
stories where else are you getting your
stories
yeah oh
yeah i didn't think of that i was
thinking
of other types of media things but yeah
the news i mean if you
if you thought that lance armstrong was
a guy to really look up to
you might reconsider the story now at a
certain point right
and then the model that he's setting um
a lot of cases we could point to like
that you know
tiger woods uh well just
pick any person wait until when you find
something on them and
you always got to wait until their life
is over because you never know at the
very end they might say something crazy
um yeah i think just like folks yeah
yes now that gets us to something really
important
uh mcintyre thinks that there are
certain
narratives that he
talks about as talks about these as
stories which provoke us to move beyond
stories
narratives which point beyond themselves
towards the theories that we in fact
need can be found in many places
what do you think he talks about he
mentions
folk tales right have you ever read
any of you ever read grimms or christian
anderson's stories
very different than the disney versions
aren't they i like the grimm's ones much
better
cinderella's sisters what happens to
them in the
disney story oh it just doesn't work out
for them
it's a relevance you know read the grim
story you'll find out there's you know
the original tale
really bad stuff happens to them and and
it kind of fits
go ahead
he mentions um sophocline of
shakespearean drama
that's kind of interesting to think
about and i'll come back to that in just
a second
uh dante's comedia which directs us
beyond itself towards
um you know something that's formed by
aquinas
now these are important stories
and this leads us to something that he
doesn't actually talk about here but is
worth
thinking about all of you had classic
texts inflicted on you
at many points in your k through 12
and i'm guessing your college education
right
um high school you probably had
four years of english and then you had
some some requirements here
and so you had to read some probably had
to read some other things that weren't
classic texts but you read some things
that are considered classics
why do we do that to you is it just you
know carrying out a cycle of abuse
sort of like drill sergeants who when i
was in the army
we would you know we would say to our
drill sergeants well you're really
treating us badly
and then he would say i was a private i
got treated like this so now i'm in
charge i get to treat you like this
and when you're in charge you'll get to
do the same thing
and then there'd be some guys to be like
yeah that sounds good
i can't wait until i get to be a drill
sergeant get to stick it to people
maybe that's how it is for for classics
you know maybe you know pushing hard
enough
on some of us professors and you know
we've mastered them so now we can be
superior to you and say yeah you
obviously misunderstood the point
read it again you know
make you feel bad
is that what it's all about it might be
for some people i don't know
you know you never know they would have
a very different orientation towards the
good
wouldn't they than a regular professor
why why are your professors
um interested in these books maybe
you're not so interested in them
but why are your professors interested
in those books
why do they get all geeky about that
yeah the lessons that they teach
like the books yeah and a lot of those
have to do with with without realizing
it they have to do with moral theory
because they're putting it in terms of
narratives if you read the odyssey
and you really spend time with it you
will find a clash of different moral
perspectives there
just think about you probably most of
you have read the odyssey right at one
time or another
and when you read it maybe some of you
actually responded to it you're like wow
this is great
because remember at one time people
actually did say yeah this is great
and that's why these books kept getting
you know
copied at one time you know it wasn't
just a printing press you had to copy it
by hand
so if it wasn't a good book they weren't
going to bother with that
if you look at the odyssey there's a
clash of moral perspectives taking place
so when the suitors when odysseus comes
home
and the suitors have been trying to kill
his son the whole time and
you know marry his wife and are eating
him out of house and home
when he goes and he kills them after
having a whole bunch of interactions
with them
you should actually have a sense of they
had it coming to them
and this is a you know right perspective
versus
a wrong perspective if you didn't get
that it was just a bunch of
you know as as the the expression goes
um sound and fury you know signifying
nothing tale told by nydia this was
shakespeare's
lines then you missed the point of it
this is part of what's going on in those
classics
how many of you
had to work your way through one of
dostoyevsky's novels
anybody crime and punishment idiot the
brothers karamazov
the possessed they're really good
why are they really good not only is he
great at attention to character
and dialogue but because there's moral
complexity there
why are the classics classics because
they're stories that have helped people
make sense
out of their lives and you may not have
responded to them
at 12 when it was first forced on you
because it didn't make any sense
it didn't correspond to the things that
you were thinking about
in your life the narrative that you had
up to that point
i mean if you read the odyssey at 12 it
was just an adventure story
it wasn't really about right and wrong
good and bad
character development it was just you
know it just you know shoved this this
thing into the cyclops's eye
and got himself out of there and that
was pretty cool and you know
that might happen but as you get older
these these things will offer you more
and more and more
so if mcintyre is right those sorts of
narratives are the
are the bridge between our individual
lives
and moral theory
and each one of them you know can embody
some sort of moral theory
now what if you're only what if you
don't have any of these classics what if
all you have is jersey shore
uh and what else should we throw in
there oprah
where i understand you know the oprah
dynasty is coming to a close but
um dr phil
uh he has narratives right narratives
are getting better
and what else should we throw in there
family court shows those are great too
if all you had was that
will that offer you the same sort of
resources for making
sense out of these really important
questions
probably not
you want to find yourself good resources
mcintyre's main point that he's making
in this too is
those good resources are going to look
more or less aristotelian
more or less like virtue ethics